now the united states has put 8 500
troops on higher alert to potentially
deploy to eastern europe if russia
attacks ukraine again president joe
biden and european leaders also held
talks by video to underscore western
solidarity in the face of what they say
is aggression from moscow ukraine for
its part says there is no reason to
panic and has called for calm russia
denies its planning and invasion and
accuses the west of being hysterical
a military standoff and a diplomatic
deadlock
almost two months since russia began
mustering troops on the ukrainian border
the situation remains as tense as ever
with negotiations stalling between
russia and the west the pentagon has
placed 8500 troops on high alert in case
nato decides to deploy
these troops are ready to support nato
states surrounding ukraine rather than
ukraine itself
again i want to reinforce that as of now
the decision has been made to put these
units on higher alert and higher alert
only no decisions have been made to
deploy any forces from the united states
at this time
in an abundance of caution the us has
also withdrawn personnel from its
embassy in kiev mainly family members
and children
but while the u.s readies itself for the
worst ukraine's president has called for
calm and unity among western nations
everything is under control there is no
reason to panic
ukraine's secretary of the national
security and defence council downplayed
the likelihood of russian invasion
there are movements of russian
federation armed forces in its territory
it takes place we detect it
but there's nothing that can surprise us
perhaps it surprised our foreign
colleagues they finally saw russian
armed forces move across their territory
russia continues to demand a promise
that nato will never allow ukraine to
join the alliance a negotiation
non-starter for nato yet as long as the
diplomatic deadlock remains so too do
fears of an invasion
for more i'm joined by dw correspondent
jack parrott in brussels good morning
the u.s has put its troops on heightened
alert while ukraine's leader is
projecting an atmosphere of calm what's
the eu's posture at this point jack
well from the european perspective there
are differing positions on this as we
know countries like france and the
netherlands and spain have already said
that they're starting to ready some
military hardware to move in if
it needs to go further into eastern
europe to try and make that sort of
stand but other countries germany
specifically
has been blocking exports of arms to
ukraine to help them to defend
themselves so there's been a few
divisions we had this phone call between
the u.s president joe biden uh the
leaders of the two major eu institutions
vonderlaan and michelle and the french
president the german chancellor the
british prime minister uh the polish uh
president as well over the uh just uh
late last night and president biden said
that this was a very very very good
meeting they're keen to make it look
like everybody
in the western partners are on the same
page i think it was very interesting
what we saw from ukrainian officials
though clearly trying now to calm their
citizens who are worried after weeks and
weeks of discussions about a potential
invasion onto their territory and what
the ukrainians were suggesting was that
actually it's not going to be an
invasion over the border that they're
worried about but rather things like
disinformation and destabilization there
have been multiple concerns that
potentially what the russians will try
and do is try and oust the government in
some way and put in uh some sort of
leadership in kiev that is favorable to
moscow that was in fact just just a few
days ago a position that was repeated by
the british foreign minister liz truss
okay so there's diplomacy going on uh
washington though is talking about
possibly deploying more troops to
eastern europe are european countries
doing the same jack
not yet what we saw yesterday was the
european commission announced a 1.2
billion euro package for ukraine
economically to try and support the
government because what russia has been
doing is sort of putting the pressure
and turning the screws on ukraine
economically so that's really where
they've been trying to to support them i
think here in europe as well we saw
after an eu foreign minister's meeting
on monday joseph burrell the eu foreign
policy chief seemed to suggest that
actually
what they heard from the american
secretary of state anthony blink and had
joined them by video for that call as
well wasn't enough for them to take
similar actions to the americans the
americans have said that non-essential
staff in their embassy in kiev should be
leaving the europeans don't see that as
much of a risk and therefore haven't
decided to move any of their diplomatic
staff out of kiev we're going to have to
wait and see how this goes further terry
there are so mixed messages generally
but also perhaps uh you know an
intention for an array of different
messages the americans are the strongest
military so therefore they make the
strongest sort of military uh statements
and the ukrainians are right on the
front line so they try and call for calm
the europeans there perhaps sit
somewhere in the middle
jack thank you very much dw's jack
parrok there in brussels
let's bring in rafael loss he's with the
european council on foreign relations
welcome to the program rafael now the
u.s is putting troops on alert for
possible deployment to eastern europe
they've also sent military hardware to
ukraine to beef up defense what about
germany berlin says it will provide kiev
a field hospital next month but will not
provide military gear to its ally can
you talk to our international audience
about berlin's stance when it comes to
exporting arms abroad
that's right berlin has announced that
it would finance a field hospital for
for ukrainian cooperation with estonia
um germany traditionally has been
hesitant and this
new german government more so than than
maybe past governments to provide
arms transfers
into conflict zones and it certainly
counts
ukraine
has for for a long time now considered a
conflict on given the ongoing russian
aggression against ukraine um
currently we see no indication
that germany would revise that stance
and there has been
some progress in this new german
coalition government to coalesce around
the same message when it comes to
putting all
measures on the table to to
deter a renewed russian aggression
against ukraine but this has sort of
raised some eyebrows among allies as
well um because for instance nordstrom 2
has been mentioned implicitly but olaf
shoulders for a long time has has been
reluctant to mention notion 2 explicitly
as a lever that
germany and its nato allies could use in
order to dissuade moscow from from going
into ukraine again i do want to talk a
little bit more about nordstrom 2 as you
mentioned that's the pipeline that would
carry russian gas into germany it's not
active as of right now u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken has said this is
leverage for the europeans this is
absolute leverage that germany has to
wield against vladimir putin has germany
made it clear enough to vladimir putin
that if his country attacks ukraine
again the nordstrom 2 is dead as you
mentioned there's some uncertainty there
about exactly what germany would do
should russia invade ukraine
well back in december germany's new
chancellor would have showed from the
social democrats and very explicitly
said that nordstrom 2 was a
business of the private sector and that
we shouldn't mix politics geopolitics
with with a private sector um business
um
some of his coalition partners
particularly in the green party for
instance german foreign during the
campaign
last year but also in recent weeks has
been a bit more explicit um the greens
have long emphasized um uh nordstrom 2
as as a potential level for germany and
nato allies to use against russia just
as russia is prone to use energy as a
geopolitical tour against
its perceived adversaries
but nonetheless um as i said the the the
german threat so far of putting
everything on the table has included
nordstrom 2 implicitly but allies are
really seeking sort of explicit
assurances um that this is that this
sort of bilateral project between
germany and russia as it is perceived by
germany's analysts is something that
that we would consider using
two dcua moscow
rafaelas from the european council on
foreign relations thank you for your
insights
you